le rapport annuel d'amnesty
international dénonce une nouvelle fois
dictature régimes autoritaires dans le
monde l'afghanistan figure encore en
bonne place malheureusement dans ce pays
livré aux obscurantistes religieux des
dernières écoles privées pour jeunes
filles viennent de fermer
on peut dire que la femme là bas est
désormais rétrogradée au rang d' être
inférieure comme en témoigne d'ailleurs
ce document filmé clandestinement dans
la capitale kaboul
philippe rochot la seule évasion pour
ces femmes prisonnières de leur voile
c'était l'école en cachette dans des
maisons privées
car depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans les religieux la police des
moeurs a fermé les écoles de filles elle
leur interdit d'étudier et même de se
faire soigner dans les hôpitaux sous
prétexte de protéger leurs vertus les
enseignantes organisait pourtant chez
elle découvre quasi clandestin que les
filles de kaboul suivait avec passion
les religieux fermer les yeux
mais à présent les leçons à domicile
sont interdites pour les talibans elle
représente un défi insupportable
les talibans ont peur qu'on se révolte
car nous sommes éduqués et e sont
incultes
il faut savoir qu'il ya aujourd'hui à
kaboul près de 800 femmes qui est unique
en estimant et si les talibans arrivent
que se passera-t-il où seront pendus et
vous peut être jetés en prison
les religieux au pouvoir à kaboul
veulent t'ils réduire les femmes à la
mendicité
en fait ces cours donnés en cachette
servait liste il entretenir une
propagande anti talibans même si les
professeurs prenait bien soin d'y
enseigner le coran
la crainte à présent pour les femmes
c'est que les religieux ne ferment aussi
ces petits dispensaires où quelques
médecins dévoués enseigne encore aux
femmes les règles élémentaires de
l'hygiène pour elles et leurs enfants